Over the past decade, China has emerged has
emerged as one of the most important markets
in the world for film distribution.
Even big-budget movies that bomb in the US
sometimes become profitable in China, like
Warcraft did earlier this year.
Still, China’s government isn’t completely
open to Hollywood films crowding their movie
screens.
Sometimes, movies get banned for reasons you
wouldn’t even think of.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of 10 Famous
Movies That Were Banned In China.
Star Wars: A New Hope
Last year’s Star Wars: The Force Awakens
was a huge hit in China last year, but ironically,
the first Star Wars was never released in
the country.
Back in 1977, the only movies that got to
play in the communist nation were produced
by the government.
Mao Zedong, the long time dictator of China,
only died one year before George Lucas made
Star Wars, and he didn’t want the people
of China to be “corrupted” by western
influences.
It wasn’t until 1994 that the government
opened up the market to only 10 foreign films
a year.
Recently, that quota has been increased to
34 foreign films per year, but it’s still
far more restrictive than most countries.
To Live
Hollywood movies aren’t the only ones to
get banned in China.
In 1994, acclaimed Chinese filmmaker Zhang
Yimou made the film To Live.
The film played at the Cannes Film Festival,
where it won the Grand Prix, and was released
across the world to fantastic reviews.
But the one place it couldn’t be released
was China.
Taking place in the early decades of China’s
Communist regime, the film was accused of
portraying the government and its policies
in a negative light.
Not only was the movie banned, but the director
was forbidden from making movies for two years.
Still, it’s regarded as a classic by connoisseurs
of Chinese cinema.
Brokeback Mountain
Brokeback Mountain is an Oscar-winning drama
about a forbidden romance between two cowboys.
Due to its subject matter, the movie was even
controversial when it came out in the United
States in 2005, so you can imagine how it
went over in China.
Chinese censors rejected the movie for its
depiction of homosexuality, but the government
was also ambivalent about the success of its
Taiwanese director, Ang Lee.
To this day, China still claims that Taiwan
is a part of its territory, from a conflict
that dates back to the Chinese civil war in
the 1940s.
Still, that didn’t stop a state-run Chinese
newspaper from declaring “Ang Lee is the
pride of Chinese people all over the world”
when he won the Oscar for Best Director.
Avatar
Avatar may be the most financially successful
movie of all time, but it didn’t get much
help from China.
Two weeks after it was released in 2009, the
Chinese government unexpectedly banned the
movie, and forced theaters to replace it with
an historical epic about the life of Confucius.
Apparently, the government was worried that
the movie’s depiction of the Na’vi -- you
know, the blue people -- would inspire a popular
revolt among the people of China.
Weirdly, however, they only banned the movie
in 2D.
It continued to play in about 900 3D theaters
after they put the ban into effect.
Back to the Future
A number of these movies were banned for political
reasons, but here’s a movie that was banned
for the grave crime of… time travel?
In 2011, China banned depictions of time travel,
which was becoming an increasingly popular
trope in Chinese film and television at the
time.
Apparently, there was concern that depictions
of time travel were disrespectful to the history
of China, especially when characters end up
re-writing Chinese history.
One casualty of this ban was the super-popular
‘80s comedy Back to the Future.
If you’ll remember, Marty McFly not only
changes the course of history in that film,
but also introduces Chuck Berry’s cousin
to the guitar riffs of “Johnny B. Goode,”
surely angering Rock-n-roll purists all over
the world.
Ghostbusters
Paul Feig’s recent reboot of the Ghostbusters
franchise was controversial in the United
States because the original film’s busters
were exchanged for an all-female cast.
But in China, it got rejected by the censors
for a completely different reason: It was
because the country is still suspicious of
movies that “promote superstition.”
Though this rule may seem silly in relation
to Ghostbusters, it often applies to films
that depict ghosts and other supernatural
beings.
Sony reportedly tried to appease censors by
removing the character for “Ghost” from
the Chinese title, but the film still wasn’t
approved for release.
Considering the film’s disappointing box
office in the US, is was probably a blow to
the studio that they’re missing out on the
Chinese audience.
Shinjuku Incident
For over a century, Hong Kong was a British
colony, separate from the Chinese mainland.
To this day, it still retains a degree of
independence over its own affairs -- including
its famous film industry.
In 2009, Hong Kong superstar Jackie Chan produced
and starred in a hardboiled crime film called
Shinjuku Incident.
While the film was released in Hong Kong without
incident, mainland Chinese censors banned
the film on the grounds that it was too violent
for Chinese audiences.
China has yet to implement a rating system
like other countries, so Jackie Chann has
made more family-friendly action comedies
in the years since.
Deadpool
Deadpool was another film that was rejected
by Chinese censors for its adult material.
Comic book fans flocked to the movie on account
of its irreverent, potty-mouthed sense of
humor, but that’s the exact same reason
it never made it to theatres in China.
Without the equivalent of an “R” rating
to keep out kids, censors had no choice but
to ban the movie entirely.
Movies are sometimes edited to appease censors
in China, but that hardly would have been
possible for a movie like Deadpool.
The Ryan Reynolds-starring superhero movie
is so full of dirty jokes and gruesome violence
that studios would probably have to cut most
of the movie to make it suitable for all ages.
The Dark Knight
Christopher Nolan’s The Dark Knight is another
comic book film that was rejected by Chinese
censors.
It’s been speculated that the film was rejected
because of a scene where Batman captures a
fugitive from an office tower in Hong Kong
and extradites him to the US to face prosecution.
The Chinese government probably didn’t like
the way Batman flouted international law or
Chinese sovereignty.
They also may have objected to a brief cameo
from singer Edison Chen.
Sexually explicit photographs of the Hong
Kong celebrity leaked online earlier that
year, and he had become quite controversial
by that point in time.
Regardless, The Dark Knight is widely available
on pirated DVDs for Chinese comic book fans.
Suicide Squad
Suicide Squad was a major hit when it was
released in the US, but it never even got
a chance in China.
Even though it was retitled to the less suggestive
“Task Force X” for a potential release,
the government hasn’t included it in their
quota of Hollywood films for 2016.
This could be because of the violence, or
because of the supernatural themes, or maybe
they just didn’t like the idea of a movie
about supervillains who become heroes.
Perhaps Jared Leto’s performance as The
Joker was just a tad bit too twisted for Chinese
authorities.
Whatever the case, it’s a big blow to Warner
Bros., whose Batman v Superman earned a big
chunk of its box office in China earlier this
year.
-
So what do you think of our list?
Were any others banned from China for crazy
reasons?
Join the discussion in the comments below,
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.